welcome back to age 20. so this section
is a preview or maybe a review of eagle
2
um depending on whether or not you have
listened to electromagnetism already
so first i just want to remind you how
we
relate electric and magnetic fields and
how we can describe them from a
different moving reference so if the
reference frame moving in x direction
then the x component of the fields do
not change but the transverse components
do change
as we have discussed before
but the core of this section is about
how the fields the electric and magnetic
fields are actually generated by charges
in that current distribution
and those this relation is described by
maximum equation so the entirety of 802
of classes on electromagnetism is about
how to understand maximum equations so
i'll do this here in a very short and
quick manner
so you can write maxwell equations in
four different equations the first one
is called gauss's law
and if you read the equation it just
says that the divergence of an electric
field gives the density of the of the
source
or the charge density of the source you
can also read this equation by saying
a charge density
generates an electric field
okay so charges generate electric field
similarly gauss's law for magnetism can
be read as
magnetic charges
generate magnetic fields
or the divergence of the magnetic fields
gives the density of the magnetic source
however in nature we haven't observed
magnetic monopoles or at least not yet
and so therefore
there's no such thing there's no
magnetic density you can read this
equation also saying that all magnetic
field lines need to be closed
and so that's another way to look at
this
then we have faraday's law which means
that you can induce electric fields
in a coil equal the negative change of
the magnetic field in other way if you
want to create an electric field you can
do this with a
charge or you can do this by changing
this as a function of time the magnetic
field
changing magnetic fields generate
electric fields
and very similarly you can look at
ampere's law and saying that
changing electric fields
generate magnetic fields
and you can also generate magnetic
fields with a current as we have seen in
the previous section
so this is
how we can understand and describe
maximum equation
the difficulty now of 802 is often to
understand the concept of fields the
fact that there's you know a vector
describing the strength of this abstract
thing of an electric or magnetic field
somewhere in space so things are
changing this time let's complicate it
and then there's also
a little bit of functional analysis
needed in order to understand and how to
find the electric field by a specific
charge
those cases can often be simplified by
having symmetric configurations like a
charge on a sphere or a point charge or
a cylinder or charges along the line in
those cases those integrals or those
divergences can be calculated rather in
a straightforward manner
okay so then there's another aspect
which is relating
charges charge distributions or fields
to forces and that's done by law and
scores so the force in the charged
particle which is moving in
electromagnetic field is given by the
strength of
the charge itself times the electric
field
plus
the velocity of the charge across the
strength of the magnetic
field okay what that means is i can if i
if i put a charge in electric field it's
being pulled it's being accelerated if i
have a moving charge in a magnetic field
it's being bent around as a force
bending it around
okay and then i can have this a
relativistic equation of motion
which uses our relativistic equation of
motion and sets this equal
to our lines
you